Шановні батьки! Якщо ваші діти готуються до вибору професії,
вам буде корисно подбати про їхню профорієнтацію
Що це таке?
Профорієнтація – це комплекс заходів, які допомагають людині обрати майбутню професію
Якісна профорієнтація складається з кількох етапів
Не слід вважати один відкритий урок у школі чи
майстер-клас комплексною профорієнтацією
Пам'ятайте, що важливим джерелом інформації
про навколишній світ для підлітка є ви, батьки
І найкраще, що ви можете зробити для того, щоб дитина вдало обрала професію, –
це створити середовище, у якому вона може контактувати з різними сферами життя
Подорожі, спілкування за межами родинно-шкільної бульбашки будуть перевагами
Як ще можна допомогти з профорієнтацією?
Дуже просто!
Помічати таланти дитини, довіряти їй, підтримувати її вибір
Отже, якісна профорієнтація – це про індивідуальний підхід і
винятковість кожної особистості
Не бійтесь довіряти своїм дітям, і нехай вони перетворять талант у справжню професію!